today is holocaust remembrance day it
was established by the united nations
so that we never forget the horrific
acts against the jewish people during
world war
ii bianca holman is live this morning at
the warsaw remembrance garden here in
the valley with more on this
bianca good morning hey good morning
john you know we've got a strong and
very active jewish community here in las
vegas
around more than 70 thousand people here
and the temple beth shalom they've been
in the community
for more than 70 years so a very strong
active community here and
here at the temple they have a
remembrance garden that remembrance
garden is named after the warsaw ghetto
in poland
now in 1940 more than 350 thousand jews
were exiled by german soldiers to a
small area
this area was enclosed by a 10-foot wall
with barbed wire and broken glass
dandelions are used to actually remember
the holocaust but the warsaw ghetto
remembrance garden here in las vegas is
a place to reflect on the atrocities
that occurred rabbi felipe goodman says
it's important to understand
why the holocaust happened
it happened because of basic prejudice
and racial bias and complete a lack of
tolerance to other human beings
and may i say that in america today with
the racial violence that we're seeing
we are always a step away to committing
horrible acts that could lead to
something like what happened to my
people
in the 40s in europe
there is a lot of education in our
public schools regarding the holocaust
susan dubin the holocaust resource
center library director tells me
they've got several training sessions
for teachers this spring and matter of
fact today there's a virtual visit to
the how did you survive
exhibit at the west charleston library
that exhibit is filled with stories from
holocaust survivors
and she also tells me we've got about
100 holocaust survivors here in southern
nevada
and if you'd like to attend that virtual
tour you must contact
susan dubin and her information is
listed on the holocaust resource
library website reporting live from town
center in
havenwood bianca holman 8 news now